i'm here to talk about product thinking
i've been talking about product thinking
ever since i started in software
development and it's
it look i started my career in
the late 1980s early 1990s working for a
small product company
and i learned software development there
that way and i
working for a product company is pretty
cool uh generally people are pretty
happy and pretty focused not always
happy but at least
focused because everybody's working
towards a common outcome now i thought
this is the way software development
worked it wasn't until
oh in the mid 2000s that i joined a big
consultancy and i started working with
larger companies and banks and insurance
companies and other people
that i realized
people don't have
product thinking isn't built in to their
organization or their culture and people
work differently
what i want to talk about is the mindset
and you've got to walk away from here
recognizing when you've got a product
mindset and when you don't and what you
can do about it because even the biggest
companies
fall out of the of this product mindset
now i've got a quick question for you
and i'm going to drop back to text here
what makes a product great
let me see if i can pull up this uh
discuss if i ask the question
uh
if i have to question what makes a
product great or or what makes it
successful what are the first words that
come to mind and you know tell me
anything that comes to mind i see uh
users love it usability value
now i'm not going to be able to keep up
values ability uh solves a user problem
fulfills the needs of the customer
who fulfills a need that's value
commercial monetary success
i uh it's early for me
my handwriting is uh
terrible uh it'll get better over time
uh makes life easier
and uh
usefulness
that makes users awesome i'm gonna get
that one
okay
that's you said more
um
then i could write down anyway
but you get the idea
what i'm look watching for let me put uh
yeah uh quality in there i saw that and
uh emotional uh resonance oh my gosh
i can't stop
writing these
now i want to point out that nobody said
finished on time or delivered under
budget
that those are not product concerns
now there's a model i draw every time
and i want to redraw just enough of it
so that you can so i can put this stuff
into context
in software development we spend a lot
of time building software
of course we start with ideas uh if
we're building a whole new product the
idea could be for a product if you've
got an existing product those ideas are
often for those
features or
enhancements
those are the things that in software
development we start referring to as our
requirements
and yeah people have heard me say this
before anybody's heard me talk has we're
trying to turn these ideas in um
well into working software uh we're
turning dollars into software to start
with and since we're turning dollars
into software we worry about the time
it's going to take
we worry about the cost the the cost
doesn't pay for raw materials it pays
for people humans all of you listening
to build this software and then all this
stuff is called scope
we spend a lot of time worrying about
time cost and scope and everybody knows
if you're building software building
technology for a living this is the
this unbreakable annoying triangle is
the bad news triangle
it's bad news because you want to know
what you can get how long it's going to
take what's going to cost but you can't
there's an old rule that you can know
any to if you fix the time and the scope
then the bad news it's going to cost
more you fix the time and the cost and
the bad news is you're going to get less
scope and you fix all three the bad news
is there's actually four the fourth one
is
quality fix all three and quality
squeezes out like toothpaste in a
toothpaste too
but
none of this is what matters what
matters to make a product successful is
well
what your
what your customers
and
users
do and say
uh look we hope that when we ship this
thing that they will see it they will
try it they will use it we hope that
they keep using it
and we hope that they say good things
and when i ask you what makes a product
great these are the kinds of good things
that people say
it's all this stuff that we're looking
for
now
look all products aren't consumer
products or by that i mean there are b2b
products or things that we build for
internal use and we don't have to worry
about whether people will see try use
and keep using it because they have to
it's their job
but uh you know while we can make them
use it we cannot make them say good
things and then we look for other
qualities like whether they become more
efficient or more effective uh by
efficient i mean
able to do more work effective doing
better work
those are the things that we look for if
we don't get those things our product
isn't great it isn't successful
and
we've got all these things that our
customers and users do and but the point
is
you all work for companies or
organizations and your organizations
does does not pay its bills with happy
customers it pays its bills with money
your organization needs to sustain
itself
and to do that it needs cash and it pays
attention to revenue and metrics and
there are people inside that watch that
and when enough people see try use and
keep using it well that's when we get
that commercial or monetary success
that's when we see things like roi or
lots of people say good things that
helps our brand awareness if lots of
people tell each other and more people
buy that helps our market share or how
we do against our competitors your
customers don't
roi doesn't solve one of their problems
it doesn't fulfill one of their needs it
doesn't make them happy roi is what your
company needs to sustain itself
we turn cache into software and then we
turn that software back into cache and
the way we do it is through this
mechanism in the middle
now i draw this thing all the time
because i want people to separate what
we build the output
from what we're focusing on when we
think about products and that's the
outcome
and outcome is measured in what your
customers and users do and say this is
super annoying our success is not what
we do it's what they do and if they
don't do it we're not successful and if
enough of them don't do it we don't get
this business
impact
impact comes as a consequence and we
measure impact inside back inside the
walls of our business that's what
matters
look now everybody knows that that
products are successful because well
because of what our customers and users
do
but yet we spend so much time worrying
about time cost and scope
now i want to change things a little bit
and i want to talk about a different
kind of business one where that time
cost and scope kind of matters a lot
more
now i realize a lot of listeners are in
india i know that we've got some
listeners that are in europe or other
places i live in the united states i
live in a city called park city utah
park city is it's high up in the
mountains and there are lots of their
ski resorts here things like that and
i'm lucky i got a lot of space and uh
and rush has seen this
but not for a while
this is my backyard or at least it was a
month or so ago my backyard was normally
kind of
crappy grass and a lot of trees and it's
not really been usable so this year
we've invested in
landscaping we've had somebody come in
with lots of equipment and
level big parts of it they've brought in
a lot of stone they've done this stone
work and created this patio and uh
the
the guy that i hired look this is troy
he's my landscaper he's has a team of
people and i have a completely different
question for you is and that's what
makes a landscaper great
so let's let me flip back and make sure
i can see what you're doing i want to
ask the exact same question
sorry let's see if i can do this uh
look if i were to ask you the question
what if you had to hire someone to do
landscaping for you and not all of you
have property to do that uh
let me good you've got it uh it delivers
delivers on time what makes you happy
uh sorry i can't write as fast uh
delivers to my needs satisfying customer
needs
quality
uh listens to you sustainability
um
and i wonder what you mean by
sustainability maybe the materials and
things like that fits the budget uh
somebody said
drawings or
prototypes things that let me be sure
i'm getting what i want uh you know yeah
cost
and by cost you probably don't mean high
cost you mean moderate cost
it creates beauty
completes on time
all right
i've missed some good things in there
because i had my head down riding uh
people said on time a couple times i'm
gonna
get that in there that's good
uh
sorry i'm having fun reading these
things uh and i can't write them all you
get it
now
let me explain the landscaping business
to you because uh well it shouldn't be
like the software business but the way
the landscaping business works is this
um i'm a customer and i uh i have a need
i have a need that i i can't fulfill
myself
so i need to find uh
a landscaper
or someone who can do this in this case
well i ended up with troy i ended up
talking with a lot of people and troy
has a full uh team of people to do
things people that do stonework and
run that equipment that's in my backyard
things like that and i explained to troy
what i want uh his job is to listen and
to
understand
now uh
you guys said listens and understands
and well he's got to create beauty and
so we go back and forth
with this description because he
ultimately needs to
figure out uh
what we're going to build how we're
going to build it and more and really
importantly how how much it's all gonna
cost and he will give me back an
estimate
now this is where in the process i throw
a wtf exception the estimate is always
more than i thought i know
look i there's a lot of things i want
and i've got a budget but i don't know
what's possible i'm not a landscaper i
don't know how much this stuff cost and
even though i gave him sort of a budget
it still was just really high this
causes me to stress and we go back in we
go into this mode i'm going to call
negotiation
where we go back and forth during
negotiation my goal is to get as much
you know as i can
or as i can afford
um but i'm focused on on my budget and i
would love it if he gave me everything
for free or
but the problem is troy has to worry
about well he has to make money so he
can't give me everything for free he's
got to pay all these people he's got to
pay for all these materials and he needs
to buy a bigger boat and a bigger house
and look he wants to make money but he
also needs to keep
his customers happy
uh
so look he's thinking of those things
while we're in negotiation
at some point in time we agree on what
we're going to build i place an order
and in this situation we agree on it
we
give him some money and he gets a job
gets to work and he does the job he
worries about the time frames we agreed
to he worries about uh
what we agreed to do the scope and he
worries about the the cost
and
all along the way he's worrying about
the quality also he he
delivers what we agreed to he focuses on
doing it on time he focuses on keeping
it beautiful and and those are the
things he's doing now during this whole
process there are problems
you know you can't predict everything
we've had situations where there are
cables buried in our yard that we didn't
anticipate so the original design didn't
work unless we moved those cables and it
was going to be too costly
and every time things kind of
weren't what he predicted we'll go back
up into negotiation go back up and
question those estimates and we go up
and down this stack an awful lot
one day troy cut my internet cable and
this sucked i was working and my
internet went completely down he
apologized he rushed electricians out to
fix it he was back within an hour or so
but
i didn't pay for that that was his
mistake and because he's making money
he's it comes out of his profit
and then well at the end
my yard is still not done it's closer to
done but i'm hoping for a delivery
now i'm drawing this whole process
because it should look very familiar
in fact let me
title the top line requirements
because this is the process that most
organizations work with this is the
process i can almost guarantee that your
company follows
in fact in most organizations
look if i re-label this
the business
and this it
the business gives requirements it gives
estimates business is never happy with
those estimates and then we go into some
negotiation mode and business is trying
to get as much as they can for their
budget and places in order things go
wrong it causes us to pop the stack go
back up to estimates and deal with
complaints and then we eventually do a
delivery that's the process we use
in fact if you look at agile development
off the shelf
i remember i started with an agile
process called
xp or extreme programming
my business card said product manager
but in xp i was referred to as the
customer or i was fulfilling the
customer role
in some cases look if i could write the
word po or product owner here product
manager and i could write team over here
and product manager builds a backlog
brings
what they want into the sprint planning
session team estimates they some
negotiation at the end of sprint
planning we agree on what we're going to
build we do the work and at the end of
the sprint we do a delivery and
we take a look at what we uh
what we're doing now
we end up focusing on all of these
qualities the annoying thing is
we're not focusing on all of these
qualities
and this starts to be the fundamental
difference between what product thinkers
are focusing on and and what we end up
focusing on
now the most
this these are all these things matter
you do have to if you don't deliver
any
output then there's no outcome uh
we absolutely need to do this stuff
predictably but it's not the thing that
matters most and if we focus too much on
this stuff this model does not work in
your organization
this model works for troy because of
this one thing here because of this
making money thing the way troy makes
money is he sells time
because he's selling time if he has too
much work all he has to do is hire more
people every single person he hires he
marks up their time and makes more money
it's an awesome business model if he has
way too much work he can hire more
people if he has way too much work well
he can uh let me write these down he can
hire more people uh he can he can just
turn down
work and
the other thing he can do is he can
raise prices
and raise prices will cause some
customers to go away and allow him to
make more money on the customers that he
can afford to work with
what's interesting is i can almost
guarantee now some of you may work for
agencies things like that but if you
work for a product company your company
does not make money selling time
if i'm using spotify or amazon i am not
buying developer time i'm buying a
product
and if i sign up for spotify i'm not
going to
judge spotify by whether they're
delivering the features i want on time
i'm going to judge spotify by these
product characteristics
this
functioning let me relabel this um this
it as a service
model is the one that i see cast into
companies and fundamentally changing the
way we work and think
see if i can position this a little bit
the important thing for you to
understand here is troy
is
my backyard is not a product
it's my backyard it's what i asked for
uh and it fulfills my vision uh i'm
gonna evaluate troy on these
capabilities and at the end of this job
troy is not the owner of the product i
am it's my product i paid for it and
look one of the things going into my
yard is this cool gas fire pit we get a
lot of snow here it's very cold and i
can turn on this fire pit and we can go
out there in the winter and it's going
to be fabulous
now i like his design and it looks good
but when that fire pit goes in if i see
it try to use it and then i decide it's
kind of dumb and i don't keep using it
it is not troy's problem it's not his
fault he is not responsible for this
outcome
that's uh it's not troy's product and if
there's more maintenance on this product
it looks mine i have to pay for it but
the annoying thing in it sometimes is it
builds a product and then they do end up
owning maintenance of it they do end up
owning it oddly so a lot of things that
make this a dysfunctional model but the
biggest single one is when we use this
model inside of our organization this is
not the way your organization makes
money the way your organization converts
that code into cash is this way if it's
building a product
now let's talk about uh
where i see
that things go wrong is people
starting to use or think that well
let's be clear about this
when you're paying for custom work
the service provider is the product
troy and his team is the product
that's the thing i look i look at troy
and his team's qualities to hire him not
the product qualities so
when you start acting like a service
provider just be clear you are the
product the thing you're building is no
longer the product
and what's more is
the process you're using may be treating
you like the product i mentioned this
about agile development and
you need to be aware the agile manifesto
was written in 2001 look it's
20 years since then agile is now the
default process but it was written from
a service provider's mindset
meaning the people who wrote this in
2001 well they were
consultants and other people and they
they have this idea as a service model
in their heads
this is why you see values like customer
collaboration over contract negotiation
i want to be able to collaborate with
somebody like troy i want to make sure
that we're on the same page and when
things change or go wrong we want to
work together if you're on either side
of that that's a better working
relationship when you're paying for
custom work that's what works but i
don't negotiate with net netflix spotify
amazon
atlassian
buy the product uh and there's not a
negotiation over the price and
definitely not a negotiation over the
features that i'm gonna that they're
going to add for me
that value just doesn't make sense from
a product context and then look the
first principle in the agile manifesto
is our highest priority to satisfy the
customer through early and continuous
delivery of valuable software
now
that's great if you're in the software
delivery business
but
amazon's not in the software delivery
business and netflix isn't in the
software delivery business and the
geo in india is in the software delivery
business uh
this the these are
that's not the thing if you were a
landscaper i could rewrite that from a
landscaper's perspective and say our
highest priority is to satisfy the
customer through early and continuous
delivery of beautiful landscaping
that works
i want you to feel when you're acting
like a service provider uh when
when you're treating the product owner
like the customer your business
stakeholder like the customer and you're
not paying attention to actual customers
and then i'll look i want to give you a
few ways to recognize or at least smell
when you're acting like the product
and i want to give you a few things you
can do to stop acting like the product
so look the first tell is that you and
your team are evaluated based on the
velocity of your work or all those
service provider characteristics
don't mistake velocity for actual value
value is comes from those outcomes they
come after things come out
so but if all your organization is
looking at are all those service
provider qualities then that's starting
to be a problem you're the product
if someone outside your team decides
what you'll build and you rely on their
approval before considering the work
done well then your team is kind of the
product
just like troy relies on me deciding
what to build and relies on me saying
it's done
then
troy can't take responsibility for the
outcome because he didn't decide what
the output was going to be
now if your biggest risks are always
whether you can deliver this tile stuff
on time or whether you've got all that
scope and if the risks aren't really
about whether the product will be
successful or whether people will use it
and love it and it will make money for a
company well then you're probably the
product if you're not aware of those
risks and
if you and your team don't actually know
the real customer
or the real customer in the real
outcomes of your work if you deliver a
product
and you don't know if people saw it try
it use it and keep using it
if the outcome is invisible or you're
gone by the time the outcome gets
generated you might be uh
you're the product
let me point out one thing this is a
hard pattern to get out from underneath
and
if look if you are the product
and you work for let's say you work for
an agency or big firm and you are hired
by another customer i want to tell you
how to there's at least one successful
way to be
to be the product but really keep your
focus on outcomes
i'm going to draw this i just drew this
continuum here
on one side of the continuum i'm going
to put the word sorry
waiter on the other side of continuum
i'm going to put the word doctor
i need you to bend more towards working
like a doctor
what i mean by that is well we know how
a restaurant works you show up at a
restaurant you order food the waiter
should listen and be attentive suggest
things to you bring you everything you
ask for the more food you order the
better and if you leave having a great
dining experience that's fabulous
but
when you show up at the doctor's office
the first thing your doctor does is to
check your kpis or look at my doctor
will check my body temperature my heart
rate my blood pressure and make me step
on a scale and check my weight for years
my doctor's been saying i'm way too fat
and i need to lose weight and my
cholesterol is high
doctors right away she starts by telling
me stuff i don't want to know uh telling
me stuff about it
that i
that i don't like to hear and look try
and give a doctor your list of
requirements tell them these are the
prescriptions i'd like you to write for
me or this is the operation i'd like you
to schedule the doctor says that's nice
tell me where it hurts
when you say the term outcome to a
doctor they know what it means it means
your health it means how you're doing it
does not mean how many prescriptions
they've written
the
doctors and real professionals focus
more on their customers outcome and if
you're gonna look if you must work in
this uh this kind of process
be more like a doctor help your
customers focus on their outcome the
same way my
my doctor helps me focus on my health
now
i wanted to finish in time to answer a
couple questions let's see if i can get
this last
chunk of stuff through
i'd like to give you a few things you
can do
right now if you're stuck in this kind
of work mode
i wonder how many pictures i can draw
here the
the first thing you do is to stop
pulling backlog items off of a backlog
and actually understand what your
products are
now
just identify your products or give them
names if they don't already have one i
think i do want to draw a picture here
because this gets hard in big companies
like if you were making spotify or you
worked for atlassian and you were
building jira you probably know what
your products are but i work with a lot
of companies that are large
banks and telcos and things like that
sorry i want to pull back i have a right
heading here
understanding what your products are
gets a little bit messy
now first thing you need to understand
is that products are composed of other
products
if you have a car or a scooter it's a
product uh and if you were to take a
wrench or a screwdriver to it and start
to take it apart all those parts are
also products you know in particular if
you pull off a tire and look at it it's
a product you can buy it separately and
the brand name on the outside of the
tire isn't toyota or uh
or honda it's it's
whoever made the tire it's a separate
product
and when we look at our products that we
build for our customers we have to
unpack them
for instance well let's uh i'm going to
call some types of products endpoint uh
products uh the the stuff we sell to our
our
our customers
if we work let me use a bank as an
example if you work for a bank your
endpoint products are things like a
checking uh account or a credit card
uh or a loan
but look for me to get it work with a
credit card or get a checking account
there are a lot of other products that
need to support that uh let's talk about
customer supporting
products
for instance if i'm going to work with a
credit card uh look i'd like to have a
website that i that i can learn about
the card or sign up for it i want to
have a mobile
app that lets me do things with that
card
look
there are also
employee
supporting products
if i work for the bank and i work in a
branch there are branch uh applications
that allow me to work directly with
customers and
uh if i work in a call center there are
call
center apps
and look all of these are products also
a mobile app is a product a website is a
product a call center app is a product
but their constituents are there part of
this whole customer experience then one
last type of product it ends up being
deep inside your organization
i'm going to call this a product
team
supporting product
and
for instance if i build apps for a bank
uh if i'm building a website for a bank
i'm gonna need to have something that
allows me to
get customer informed show customer
information show current balances things
like that same with a mobile app same
with branch out same with call center
apps i want every one of these product
teams to rebuild their same stuff so we
often externalize and we have uh
things like uh
common
services or components
those are products but well the primary
customer for these common services or
components well the primary customers
written in the name it's other product
teams and the other product teams see
try use and keep using and say good
things about the components and if they
don't you suck as a
as a product supplier team you need to
be aware of who your customers are and
every one of these kinds of product
teams your your customers are you know
clearly indicated
maybe one other thing to point out here
is a product
these back end product team supplying
products have a way of drifting outside
of your company and they end up becoming
uh
well
partner supporting
uh people like salesforce years ago had
an internal framework they used to build
their product but sales forces
the lifted
drifted outside and now people commonly
build apps on that force framework some
of you probably do that for a living
today
work with lots of organizations where
what they built here when they treat it
like a product
well it migrates out here pretty
effectively
understand what your products are and
then once you understand what those
products are now you've got a
look
you've got a few things you can do
first
oops sorry that's not i've got too many
decks open here
the
first thing to do is to actually
evaluate the success of your products
today what are people seeing and saying
about the product you've already got if
you're responsible for the outcomes
take some time and understand well
what's our what the outcomes you already
have are if you ship that product is it
getting used what features get used the
most which don't and you may not have
data on these things but trust your gut
or talk to people gather anecdotal
information now i talk about building
simple models that help a team
understand your product
i build things like simple personas that
let people understand who our customers
are and what their concerns are and
things like well they're like a story
map but a journey map that describes the
product we have today and where its
problems are
once you understand your customers
really get to know who who those
customers are
meet them talk to them or talk to other
people at least that talk to them
now i keep using the term customers and
users and we conflate these things all
the time customers choose a product
users use a product for consumer
applications they're the same people the
chooser and user are the same people but
look if you're using jira in your
company i can guarantee you didn't
choose it but you you use it you're a
user b2b products users and choosers are
separate make sure you understand that
and well understand how your customers
get value from it and how your users use
it and do their jobs with it
all right fourth thing here is
once you understand your product what
your product is how it's going now what
your who your customers are and what
they want out of it you're going to find
opportunities for improving your product
as as it is
contemporary products
continuously improve that they don't
improve with big fat releases there's no
cool next new version of spotify coming
there's no next new version of i don't
know what other applications no next no
cool new version of jira or trello
coming rather they continuously improve
with lots of small changes and product
teams are the ones responsible for the
outcome so they well they identify their
own backlog items ideally
but
before you build anything talk about the
expected outcome
uh what do we expect
who will use this functionality how
often will they be more efficient and
more effective and then for extra credit
how would we actually measure if they
were how do we measure who's using it
and how often and how fast they can do
things or how many errors they make when
they're doing it this sets us up to
measure outcomes not just
this sets us up to measure outcomes if
now
yeah that last bullet is you need to
understand that the relationship between
outcome and impact
last thing and i can give you this see
if i can do this in a minute so we only
have five minutes for questions um look
if your
if your organization ships and if you're
using an agile process today i can
almost guarantee that at the end of
every sprint or iteration you stop and
reflect on your velocity or your quality
or how well you did you'll you might
demonstrate their product and
stakeholders might say they like it or
that's good but that's not the outcome i
want you to continuously reflect on the
outcome and impact of everything you
deliver
um let me draw a just a very quick model
i can do this in
one minute i'm already too late as it is
if you've got a feature
and remember a feature isn't a story or
isn't a backlog item it sometimes takes
lots of backlog items to build a feature
you can release after you release every
feature look at
stop and talk about the actual effort it
took meaning
if it was small it took days or uh if it
took days or weeks it's going to float
to the left if it took months it's going
to float into the middle if it took uh
quarters it's going to float to the
right where did things actually end up
now you might have predicted things were
going to take a few weeks but they took
a few months and if they were longer
than predicted i'll ask people to note
what took longer than we predicted of
course they're going to be on the right
hand side you're going to quickly see
that little things are more predictable
than big things just the way it is
but then i want you to look at the
actual
outcome
now everything you ship starts in the
don't know category
meaning
if i just barely shipped it or haven't
shipped it yet i don't know what the
outcome is because i can't measure
outcome until things come out
but when users start to see it and try
it and use it you've got a scale here
that at the top is awesome meaning
people used it the rate we thought they
loved it the bottom is uh awful
uh people used it hated it complained
and in the middle is this uh
meh zone and the problem is you can't
talk about this at the end of every
sprint
you have to talk about this over time
you may have to wait weeks or months to
be able to start getting outcomes and
things will start to bubble up or start
to move around
the first thing you're going to see or
realize is that how long something took
has nothing to do with the outcome uh
you'll find that little things get
awesome outcomes and big things can get
awful outcomes you'll also find that how
late something was has nothing to do
with the outcome i can deliver something
on time and it can still be awful i can
deliver something
late and it can still be
awesome
it
there's no correlation
between
this is the confounding thing how well
you do with this has very little to do
with how well you do at that outcome
thing
being product centric shifts your focus
to those outcomes and
look i'm hoping you can start to smell
you know what i mean by this and start
to feel it inside your organization
product thinking moves your focus to
outcomes the success of the product
you're creating and improving
not just the effort it took to do it
don't mistake being a good service
provider being reliable and dependable
and delivering what you said you would
for being a good product developer
they're not the same thing and your
company succeeds when its product
succeeds
if your product is a service like my
friend troy he's going to be successful
when he is reliable and does all those
right things but hey if you work for a
company that actually builds a product
it's going to succeed when your
customers actually use your products and
love those things
all right i blew it uh
only two maybe time for one question if
that but the